what's your favorite part about BuzzFeed
fair part is most feet are like the nice
people like ever
awesome well I'll take that compliment
for myself too what's up guys I'm Yvonne
and today we're here at the Teen Choice
Awards playing a fun game of butcher
rather with celebs let's see who we get
would you rather sing along with High
School Musical Zac Efron or the greatest
showman Zac Efron oh okay my little me
has to say High School Musical Zac Efron
because I was in love like any load High
School Musical I guess I'm not sorry
it's a classic right back to the roots I
just well I just saw the greatest show
in like a month ago the best movie oh my
gosh it was so amazing so I would choose
him High School Musical destroy boring
he's like a classic right yeah do you
have a favorite song I tell you what
what what's the name of the song where
he's on the golf course bet on it
classic do you still know a little bit
of the song
I see would you rather go on a double
date with Veronica and Archie or a
Jughead and Betty I'm a bug headband so
for Jughead and ready yes I just think
they're so cute I love that they're
dating in real life allegedly quickly
one can dream
Jughead and Betty yeah why is that I
don't know I feel like they'd have more
fun Archie and Veronica wait what is
that you got the inside scoop
maybe you spicy they're always hooking
up everywhere who knows probably answer
chaining to watch would you rather get
in a fight with a demo Gorgon from
stranger things or Pennywise the clown
from it uh definitely penny wise why I
don't know I have like a weird
infatuation with him what's not
expecting that but okay so look at that
we're almost the same height now which I
rather have cheeto dust fingers forever
or wear wet socks forever cheeto dust
why because I couldn't stand walking
around on what
never wet socks I have a thing about
feet in general right now and so
all the way because I mean I would be
eating Cheetos all the time it's just a
good thing I love she would you rather
be able to speak any language fluently
or be able to talk to animals why is
that because I feel like I can still
communicate with people even when I
don't speak their language but animals
we don't forget just a whole different
ballgame and I love animals speaking to
animals like that's a true gift and like
just to get in that vine like what are
you thinking what are you saying to me I
love you
[Music]